wow babe
next contestant hailing from pasadena
[Music]
california
i can't resist i showed her the pies the
new pies i got
wow they're not rude and then she goes
did you see the cheesecake
you did this is what bobby considers a
fine cake
oh my god this is the best thing i've
ever eaten in my life
so good i thought you got a fancy like
beijing store or something
it's
[Music]
oh no there he goes
oh my god george congrats how far along
is she
um it's uh trying to master it's like
enough to like we just yeah we got the
test that like that's a little uh baby
boy
it's all healthy it's all uh how awesome
george congrats oh my god
your [ __ ] works dude george's the dad
everyone
we did it i'm gonna go tell bobby
well i'm happy that well it proves a
couple of things number one that
i didn't believe that even ever had sex
nope kicking let me touch our babies
kicking
kicking it's playing soccer
in there thank god for berries
i thought you were gonna get squished
yeah my drinks are here
you don't love me it's here
can you explain why the fridge is now in
the middle of the living room
because i just felt like switching it up
a bit you know
he's not a friend he's someone i'm
talking to
oh you're sexy sexy is it sexual no
it's you like him kind of yeah you do
excuse me what did you say to me oh
that's
that's that's what do you think of that
see that's how fast that happens but
because he wasn't be able to help the
klingons because the clean
that one event made the federation
klingons become
allies the klingons are now
in a war in the future still with the
federation you understand what i'm
saying
not really no be real you don't
understand no i don't
what are you confused about
as well he's a hard working kid he's
he's a
great guy he's a friend of ours has he
done tiger belly
he has yeah
i don't know it's a basket full of um
goodness from the chryslers open it up
is it a blanket yeah i think so or i
don't know it looks like it no don't put
it on the floor
she was supposed to buy you a cake okay
that's your responsibility
and then she and then and i asked her
just now where's the cake and she's like
what cake i'm like the cake you're
supposed to buy for her birthday happy
birthday
to you happy birthday
to you
one okay good two three
four five six
seven eight nine
ten wow good job babe
and what would you have preferred she
had done
just speed up during the speed bumps
you know that's what i do and then also
um
i don't look when i turn guys we're here
to
uh chat with a very special guest you
guys may know her as
jules the very few of you some of you
may know her as
bad friend rudy favorite street food i
miss
the mango and
i forgot the other one it's her favorite
so much that she forgot
oh i can relate so much to this give us
the top five animes people must listen
to right now
or watch right now hunter hunter
and then akamiga kill made
zama it's a love story but it's really
cute
assassination classroom that's the last
one after
assassination classroom tokyo goal
oh there we go that sounds nice um
anymore have you
had any uh knife dreams lately yeah i
think i had
one last week still about stabbing
people stop looking at me every time you
say something negative she like looks
like she looks like i hate men i want to
stab people like the whole time she's
looking all over the room and anytime
you ask her a question and that she has
a negative answer it looks
into my soul
[Music]
the soups are getting cold i know so
what i don't even know what's going on
you have to taste the soups and then you
have to vote which one is the best
okay well can i just before i even taste
it let me just
describe each one visually the one to
the right is chunky
it's like if you haven't like let's say
an elephant has hasn't masturbated in
nine months
right let's suppose an elephant didn't
masturbate for nine months right
and he finally unloaded this would be it
this looks like sewage water
this right here is what you get in some
sort of vegas buffet
yeah one two three okay jules do you
want to get in there and taste
this is first yeah second and third no
that's it's not it's you're wrong where
you
swear to god on your mother's life did
you know that that was your sue
yeah okay exactly so you're gonna you're
gonna not hurt somebody's feelings
no but if you yes she was gonna hurt her
own feelings because she let me say
something
let me say something yeah and also you
helped make this
yeah right so for you to choose this
second is gross
but she's just being honest about her
own work no
how could you choose your own goal yeah
mine's better
i just peeled the potatoes that's it
i didn't add any flavor to anything else
oh did you just fart you fart
how long do you think you can hold hands
with me the whole time let's do it all
right
wait hold on that's not really hold
hands like intertwined
come
no we're all three holding hands like
that see you take it too far where the
back pocket's now wait my thumb in the
butt
so you grew up in the burbs this is this
is like
woodland hills i know i grew up i grew
up
upper middle class there's a pool that
we grew up with see there's a pool in
there yeah we had a pool
so you're like a rich white guy [ __ ] you
um to the people that are the patreon
images
uh i want to say a special message to
you and that message is um
a very simple one merry christmas happy
hanukkah
happy happy happy new year
i was trying to say have a happy new
year
have a happy happy happening here and um
i really appreciate you guys and
um it's called karate
[Music]